(orchestral music)
- All right gentlemen.
Crank it up!
(orchestral music)
I was naive enough to believe
that I could do something
that people said couldn't be done.
But if you really want
to do somethin' new,
you've gotta go where it's scary.
Lyle Small, I'm the president
of Chromatic Technologies.
We make the ink that makes
the mountains turn blue
when it's cold on the Coors Light can.
(inspirational music)
(ice crackling)
I'm just a nerd that makes
goo that changes colors.
To make it great I need
somebody like Kiri Leigh.
- Hi.
- I'm Kiri.
- Hi Kiri, I'm Lyle.
- [Kiri] Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
Welcome to CTI.
Kiri Leigh Jones and I
have partnered together
to bring her artistic talent,
and CTI's color change
cold technology together
and create a unique piece of art.
And I'm so excited to see
what'll happen with it.
- I paint mostly murals.
So I've just always believed
that everything is a canvas.
I love to experiment.
I just always wanna be learning.
So kind of what I'm envisioning
for this big art project
is the concept of a kaleidoscope.
The kaleidoscope's gonna
go in and out of the colors
like you're looking through a snowflake
and these are all the colors that
are coming out.
- Oh, fantastic.
So it'll be complicated,
but create an invisible piece
of art that comes to life
when you make it cold.
So the idea would be, we
have this platform here
that has a chilled background to it.
- I've never seen anything like this.
- No, no.
- Never heard of anything
like this.
- No.
Who would be crazy enough to do it, right?
- Us.
- Yes, that's right.
(Kiri laughing)
(inspirational music)
- I am painting a giant refrigerated,
aluminum canvas
with the color-changing paint
that cools down to be in color,
and then when it's at room
temperature, it's white.
So it basically looks like it's invisible.
He kept saying it was
invisible (chuckling).
And I kept thinking
there's no possible way.
But, yeah, no.
It's definitely invisible.
It looks kind of pink and
then it goes away immediately.
(playful music)
After hearing Lyle talk about it
and being so specific about the degrees
that it was gonna change,
I was
very confused.
(chuckling) I was very confused.
My biggest qualm is mixing the colors
and not being able to see it.
So I'm interested to see
if all the colors stayed.
(playful music)
I will know in nine degrees.
All the colors are showing up.
It reacts with the cold pretty quickly.
So it's very easy now (chuckles)
to see where I'm painting, which is cool.
Hi.
- Hey.
- How are you?
- Oh, I'm great.
That is beautiful.
- So it's supposed to
look like a kaleidoscope.
So when it starts to cool down,
you'll start to see
all the changing colors
and all of the things come to life.
- How nice.
All right, so let's check this out here.
Oh, wow.
It's crazy, it's like
I'm discovering the piece
as I'm spraying it.
- Yes.
- I mean, I had no idea
all this stuff was in here.
- [Kiri] And I'm discovering that I forgot
to put green paint right there.
(both laughing)
I want everyone to be
standing in front of it
and literally feel that exhale of coldness
as it rushes over them.
- I hope that when they see it,
they get the sense that
something magical has happened.
(inspirational music)